but morning in dorsum ladies and
gentlemen and dear guests from abroad
and polish colleagues first of all I
would like to thank FTTH cancel Europe
for choosing who are so as a host of
next edition of the biggest FTD
age-related conference in the world it's
honor to follow such great cities as
Stockholm London Munich and Milan I know
that many of you had the opportunity to
participate in the previous conference
and you know how intense and enjoying
this event is but despite busy shuttle
as minister said I hope that you will
find a moment to visit war suicide and
enjoy it its history and beauty if you
try I'm sure you will not regret it now
i will try not to take too much
attention but at the same time i would
like to give you summary of the most
important issues about broadband in
poland if you require more information
ensure that it will be possible with
talking with our strong
telecommunication polish enterpreneurs
here they are present here in this floor
so Poland is one of the largest new
countries with population over 30 a
million and what's important we were not
affected by the global economic crisis
its natural that volunteer is also and
the biggest telecommunication market
with a lot of potential thanks to its
stability and lively competition today
there is over 24 millions regular
internet users at the end of two
thousand thirteen almost fifty percent
of Polish household were covered
buying it MGA networks and almost 40% of
fixed brand subscriptions were above 30
megabyte megabyte per second per second
which is much higher than average in you
in you this average is 21% of course
several service providers offer one
gigabyte and in our cities speed like
100 megabytes and above becomes a
standard we also that at what I should
underline have legal regulations which
required to each new multifamily
building have to be equipped with
telecommunication installation based on
fiber optics don't be afraid I am not
such a fan of PR success we had our
problems too like everyone does but
since you are dealing with them it's
nothing to be ashamed of the most
important thing is the digital divide
some people only because of the place of
residence primal-dual our ass can't take
advantage of tools available in the
digital world it's unfair and a lot of
has to be done there is no magic mixture
they will switch everyone but for us
that is the Polish government there are
some very important ingredients that we
have to use simultaneously these are
clear vision set of goals people and
cooperation as a ministry of
infrastructure and development we are
responsible for strategic approach to
countries developed in the mid term
perspective and method and managed yo
fans when it comes to broadband and ICT
in general I have to underline that
almost every important governmental
strategic document recognized broadband
as a one of the main factors for growth
of our economy and our people and when
we are talking about people and
cooperation I can't hesitate to
introduce my dear governmental
colleagues with whom you are dealing
with broadband issues in Poland minister
and rahael its key who spoke to you just
before its mastermind of a life of
Polish Digital Agenda and ministry
magdalena guy our national regulatory
will give a speech in may in a moment
it's a head engineer of this operation
I'm a chief accountant who embraces the
whole process and takes care of
efficiency and procedures what is what
is most important in this puzzle is that
that we have built strong bridges
between our institutions and we work as
well managed company together we speak
with private sector because and this
obvious and simple there is no other way
to learn which solution is good and two
it is not for market I believe that this
effective model of cooperation it's only
way to make real change in Poland going
to this specific solution under last in
your financial perspective we decided to
allocate over 1 billion euro for
broadband networks deployment as a
result we are in the process of
constructing around 5000 8,000
kilometers of broadband networks mainly
now backbone and distribution networks
most of which are based on optical fiber
technologies around nine million poles
live in Arras which will be served by
new broadband networks
at the same time with new er financial
perspective it means 2014-2020 we
developed operational programme digital
Poland which is dedicated to development
of broadband infrastructure in
government and digital skills as
Minister set y all together under one
program we strongly believe that ICT
these days is a network of connected
vessels so we have to find the right
balance and support all those RS so
going back to to broadband till 2023 we
plan to spend another 1 billion euro for
broadband networks of course mainly now
for last mile and help to achieve
national broadband plan go which is
universal access at least 30 megabytes
per second to 2020 for all our habitants
funds will be used for the development
of high-speed broadband networks in our
areas where public support is necessary
to undertake profitable business the
first competition for broadband projects
will be announced before the end of this
year we look forward to a lot of
interest from private enterpreneurs
thanks to this project Poland is the
largest broadband construction site in
Europe for now and hopefully for years
to come what it means to you and by you
i am in private telecommunication sector
i think this means a lot of investment
opportunities here in poland for almost
everyone in the market from classical
telecommunication operators from vendors
to construction companies since we don't
want to just spend some offense but make
a big step towards digital economy and
resolve the problem of digital divide in
polar
we will need the best technologies
available and the technology is the one
thing that I am not worried about why is
that because I know that even at this
moment in your factories and research
centers around the world thousand of
top-class engineers works on the
development of the most efficient and
cost-effective broadband solution that
may contribute to the development of
high speed internet in Poland and in
this point I encourage you to cooperate
with us to build our energy centers here
in Poland and commercial is a your R&D
result in economy including
telecommunications brands ladies and
gentlemen events events like this always
have the potential to leave a mark in
history of telecommunication with some
game-changing speeches or presentation
of new solutions this can happen on this
floor during panels and workshops or
informal networking so I strongly
encourage you to squeeze your time
inverso to the maximum thank you for
attention
you